in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
doctor arena in Tasya she's a vascular
surgeon at the charity belly welcome to
the show hi
what causes plaques inside vessels in
the first place
we think today that there's an injury in
the inner layer of the artery which
causes then a deficit of Cola soul and
calcifications and some proteins which
build up this kind of block which is
which narrows the artery and this plaque
can burst up and then this can induce
blood coagulation and clotting of the
blood and then the artery is closed or
very narrow but before it closes there's
an injury inside the artery wall so
hypertension high blood pressure
yes hypertension is one of the causes
which can cause this injury so what
about smoking smoking is a very high
risk factor for atherosclerosis
mm-hmm so so if I want to prevent my
arteries from getting clocked I should
stop smoking then yes what stop smoking
yes good I mean I'm not smoking since
just make it yeah and so and what about
cholesterol high cholesterol levels as
well our high risk factor for
atherosclerosis as well diabetes
mellitus or risk factor obesity is a
risk factor and the male gender SS was a
risk factor and if a patient's got
diabetes is it too late for the arteries
or can you still reverse the process
happening inside the arteries if you
treat diabetes as well a reverse is
is it's not possible but you can stop
the progress or diminish the progress
and best way is that the sugar levels
and the plot are really in the norm some
recent research suggested an
inflammation inside the artery wall
might cause the clotting so and if I
would reduce information for instance by
taking aspirin do you think there's any
benefit for them we think that the
effect of the aspirin is more the
antiplatelet effect not effect of
inflammation because we give the aspirin
and a very low dosage so it's more for
the platelets not against the initiation
and as a patient what are the first
signs and that I should see a
professional or whatever symptoms
unfortunately the first signs they are
not very early signs the we see the
patient's when the damage and the
restless' already very high so the
patient comes to us because he has leg
pain or chest pain or he has a
serrations on the legs which are not
healing this some signs that they are
not early they're quite late yes that
you don't have early signs and this
disease so the body can be its own
surgeon in a way building you collateral
arteries and so what can I do as a
patient to promote this can I just start
start and go for a walk or do you need a
professional trainer to help me so this
is our first recommendation that the
patient has to start to walk and he can
buy a dog and walk every day the
recommendation is to walk just until the
pain starts and then to relax and then
walk again a lot of patients don't have
the motivation to do this every day by
themselves so we could recommend as well
that they go in a special vascular
walking exercise
where they can do this exercise together
with other patients but it's just for
motivational reasons it's not because
it's dangerous if I start walking just
because it's and I don't walk into the
pain I just walk into the threshold
threshold off the paint then I stop for
it yes yes if you walk in the pain you
will have the pain which reduces the
motivation to work and on the other hand
for the muscle it means that there is
then the lack of oxygen which just not
so good for the muscles or better just
until the threshold and then relax and
move again that's the best of to induce
the building of collateral so it's not
the i schemer inside the muscle it's
more like the training itself that's
great
as a surgeon you've got plenty of
procedures waiting at the operation
table so what are the most common
procedures for artery disease today we
have two methods the one is an
endovascular method where you punctured
the adhere vessel and go in with a
catheter and then you can put in another
catheter which has a balloon on his tip
and you can place this in the narrow
area deflate the balloon and compress
the deficit in the aterial wall and to
keep the vessel open usually we put then
in kind of mesh tube we call them stands
to keep the vessel then open these are
the endovascular procedures the other
way is that we do open surgery in this
case we really open the arteries and
remove the plaques which is called and
art erect to me the other possibility if
pursue stenosis of the artery is too
long then we can can perform bypass
graft surgery mmm so you just take
another whistle and bypass the stenosis
yes we take another whistle sometimes a
vein or an artificial wrestle and this
works like a collateral
so what about prognosis of those
procedures is there any procedure better
than the other no because we can't heal
we can't cure we can only repair and we
always would start with a less invasive
method and then go on with more invasive
procedures yes
so as you're not not really healing
you're just you're not curing you're
just treating the symptoms so so you're
not just a doctor
you were person yourself you're human
yourself what do you do for your
vascular health so I have two advantage
I'm a woman I try I'm not a nonsmoker I
try to have a healthier lifestyle and as
well I try to have some physical
activity of like swimming so it comes to
sport it comes to am having a great job
thanks for having you on the show thanks
so much